vous avez la parole au nom de la
commission des affaires économiques
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui adopter à l'unanimité par la
commission des affaires économiques la
semaine dernière vise à encadrer
l'influence commerciale et à lutter
contre les dérives des influenceurs sur
les réseaux sociaux cette proposition de
loi est importante car très attendue de
nous concitoyens et c'est grâce à une
initiative parlementaire transpartisane
que cette demande populaire a pris la
forme d'un texte de loi je tiens ainsi à
saluer les travaux des deux rapporteurs
de la commission des affaires
économiques de l'Assemblée nationale
messieurs donc Stéphane vogeta et Arthur
de Laporte qui ont su collaborer pour
aboutir à une initiative commune et
concertée les premiers travaux
parlementaires menés sur ce sujet
nouveau pour les législateurs que nous
sommes vont dans le bon sens et méritent
d'être confortés ce sujet est nouveau
car c'est la première fois en Europe
qu'un texte de loi transversal visant
spécifiquement à réguler l'activité des
influenceurs sera adopté encore une fois
les parlementaires français sont à
l'avant-garde de la régulation de
l'économie numérique et je ne vous
apprends rien en vous disant qu'ici au
Sénat il s'agit d'un sujet qui attire
tout particulièrement notre attention et
qui fait l'objet de nombreux travaux ce
sujet est nouveau car même si les
influenceurs et les réseaux sociaux font
désormais partie du quotidien de nos
concitoyens ce secteur d'activité
demeure peu documenté et mal connues des
pouvoirs publics ainsi selon les
premières estimations à notre
disposition il y aurait 150 000
influenceurs en France dont seulement
15% exerceraient cette activité à temps
plein ce sujet est nouveau également car
il pose la question de l'adaptation de
notre droit national de nos outils de
contrôle et de régulation aux
spécificités de l'économie numérique
si notre droit est suffisamment souple
et robuste pour s'adapter à cette
nouvelle forme d'activité commerciale
nos outils de contrôle et de régulation
mérite quant à eux d'être largement
renforcé c'est dans cet état d'esprit
c'est dans cet esprit que j'ai abordé
mes travaux au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques avec un seul
objectif mieux comprendre le secteur de
l'influence commerciale sans aucun
préjugé et adapté en conséquences la
proposition de loi qui nous a été
transmise enfin dans améliorer la portée
et l'effectivité je tiens ainsi à
remercier mes collègues pour avoir
contribué à l'élaboration de ce texte
collègue issu de tous les bancs de
l'hémicycle je tiens à le souligner et
je ne manquerai pas de les citer lors de
l'examen du texte ils ont permis à la
commission d'adopter un texte plus juste
plus ciblé et rééquilibré
pour définir ma feuille de route
politique sur ce texte je me suis posé
trois grandes questions la première
celle de savoir si l'influence
commerciale est une activité comme les
autres c'est la question peut sembler un
peu provocatrice il faut bien
reconnaître un paradoxe l'activité
d'influence commerciale et désormais
bien imbriquée au sein de notre économie
présentant des avantages certains pour
les entreprises mais nos concitoyens ont
le sentiment que ce secteur demande
demeure totalement déréguliers les
pratiques de certains acteurs
malintentionnés masques aujourd'hui la
réalité d'un secteur en plein
développement les difficultés de
régulation du secteur de l'influence
commerciale par les pouvoirs publics
sont réels d'abord en raison de la
hausse du nombre d'influenceurs du
volume de contenu publiés et du
caractère de plus en plus éphémère de
ses contenus je parle notamment des
stories des lives c'est à dire des
publications instantanées ou en direct
c'est pourquoi il est apparu
indispensable d'adapter les missions des
autorités de régulation en renforçant
par exemple les pouvoirs de police
administrative de la DGCCRF ou encore
d'étendre la procédure de blocage
judiciaire de l'Autorité des marchés
financiers aux promotions d'offres
illicite ensuite parce que de très
nombreuses publications touchent un
public français sont émises par des
influenceurs Français résidant en dehors
de l'Union Européenne notamment aux
Émirats arabes unis et aux États-Unis
alors même que leur notoriété s'est
construite auprès de ce public il m'a
semblé indispensable de rattacher ses
influenceurs à la proposition de loi que
nous examinons en maintenant le principe
de soumission aux droits français des
contrats d'influence commerciale et en
leur imposant de désigner un
représentant légal établi sur le
territoire de l'Union Européenne et ce
afin de faciliter la coopération avec
les autorités administratives et
judiciaires nationales
les travaux de la commission des
affaires économiques ont permis de poser
les jalons les premiers jalons d'un
dispositif que je vous proposerai de
conforter tout à l'heure pour démontrer
à nos concitoyens que l'activité
d'influence commerciale peut être une
activité économique comme les autres
nous devons donc renforcer son contrôle
sa régulation et son encadrement je me
suis posé également une deuxième
question celle de savoir si l'influence
commerciale et était un canal
publicitaire pardon comme les autres
c'est sans doute sur ce point que le
sujet sur lequel nous débattons n'est
pas si nouveau devons-nous appliquer aux
influenceurs les mêmes règles
interdictions encadrement que celle
existante par exemple pour la télévision
la radio ou les plateformes de partage
de vidéo contrairement aux idées
largement exprimées ces derniers temps
l'activité d'influenceurs n'est pas
totalement dérégulée toutes les règles
existantes aujourd'hui en matière de
publicité et de promotion s'appliquent
aux inf douceur nous devons le rappeler
en revanche nous devons reconnaître que
ces règles ne sont aujourd'hui pas
connues mal comprises et non respectées
pas connu et mal comprises car il n'y a
pas de formation de diplôme ou de
certifications obligatoires pour devenir
influenceur ou agent d'influenceurs mal
appliquée car il y a aussi des abus
intentionnels de la part de certains
influenceurs et de certains annonceurs
d'ailleurs il me semble pardon donc
important avant d'interdire et de
sanctionner davantage de commencer par
faire preuve de pédagogie à l'égard des
acteurs du secteur de clarifier les
règles du jeu afin d'accompagner un
secteur qui doit encore se structurer
c'est notamment pour cela que nous avons
voté en commission l'affichage
obligatoire de la mention unique
publicité sur les publications
commerciales des influenceurs nous avons
également voté l'affichage obligatoire
de la mention images virtuelle afin
d'anticiper les conséquences de
l'intelligence artificielle sur la
publicité en ligne et le marketing
d'influence dans tous les cas les
objectifs de ces mentions sont les mêmes
faire preuve de davantage de sincérité
et de transparence à l'égard des
internautes et des consommateurs une
fois le caractère commercial d'une
publication clairement identifiée nous
devons déterminer les promotions
réalisées par les influenceurs qui
méritent d'être autorisés interdite ou
encadrés la Commission a donc souhaité
rééquilibrer les dispositions votées qui
concernent les secteurs de
l'agroalimentaire du commerce en ligne
et des crypto actifs
un durcissement excessif des
dispositions votées sur ces trois sujets
risqueraient d'avoir des effets de
rebord de bord pardon indiscera indésira
indésirables par ricochet sur le bon
fonctionnement de notre économie un pan
global qui ne doit pas être pénalisé par
une proposition de loi visant
spécifiquement l'influence commerciale
l'influence commerciale est ainsi à la
fois un canal publicitaire comme un
autre mais avec des spécificités nous
devons donc être prudents et ne pas
adopter des dispositions trop
contraignantes pour notre économie mais
en même temps être vigilant ou regarder
conséquences spécifiques sur notre santé
publique et notre jeunesse
troisième et dernière grande question
que je me suis posée sur les dérives de
l'influence commerciale
précisément de quel dérive parle-t-on
les objectifs de protection de la santé
publique de protection de la jeunesse de
protection des consommateurs et des
épargnants me conduisent à penser que
des interdictions promotionnelles
supplémentaires et spécifiques sont tout
à fait justifiés en matière de
protection de la santé publique en plus
de l'interdiction de promotion de la
chirurgie esthétique la Commission a
souhaité interdire toute forme de
promotion incitant directement ou
indirectement à l'abstention
thérapeutique au profit de la
consommation de bien ou service présenté
comme substitua préférable comparable à
un traitement médical au regard de la
hausse des dérives sectaires sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est indispensable en matière de
protection des enfants et des
adolescents la Commission a souhaité
également renforcée le régime
d'information portant sur les promotions
de jeux d'argent et de hasard en
obligeant les influenceurs à afficher un
bandeau interdit au moins de 18 ans il
s'agit ici de sensibiliser à la fois les
internautes mineurs qui contourneraient
les systèmes déclaratifs de vérification
d'âge mais aussi leurs parents et leurs
familles enfin en matière de protection
des consommateurs et des épargnants la
Commission a souhaité être à l'écoute
des collectifs de victimes et interdire
la promotion d'abonnement à des
pronostics sportifs ou regards des
grands événements sportifs à venir le
risque d'arnaque est particulièrement
élevé voilà donc mes chers collègues
notre feuille de route pour l'examen de
cette proposition de loi vous l'aurez
compris
l'objectif n'est pas tant d'interdire
l'influence commerciale mais d'encadrer
son développement afin de ne pas
sanctionner de mieux sanctionner pardon
que les acteurs malintentionnés qui
décideraient malgré cette proposition de
loi de ne pas respecter le cadre légal
je vous remercie merci la parole dans la
décision générale et